The joe rogan experience.
Can I just give one interesting UFC memory for me please?
I watched the very first UFC one a with,
I had a troop at the time and we invited a scout troop.
It wasn't,
it was a comedy troupe and they have a voice will we dressed as a boy scouts,
but we invited Neil Patrick Harris over.
It was 20 years old at the time he was in town.
We just met him and he came over and soon as the sumo wrestler,
God,
his face kicked in and there's spit a tooth out.
I believe.
He was like,
I'm Outta here.
I gotta get out.
And we made him stay and watch the whole thing.
Good for you.
And that's what made him gay.
While that was,
thanks for ruining the story,
Dave.
I don't know if that's true.
I don't know.
Something happened.
Maybe someone dropped him on his head.
Yeah,
I don't think he knows.
He looked like he was already as a kid.
Something wrong or right.
Depending on if you're his boyfriend.
Yeah.
Imagine it depends if he's a good boyfriend,
right?
Yeah.
Well,
yes,
but I mean if the husband,
the husband,
yeah.
The guy's really into him.
Like thank God you watch that fight,
that time.
God thank God.
Otherwise could have never found chick.
Yup.
Who knows.
Look at Abby's and shit.
Oh God.
And these are places which have levels of violence,
which are like way worse than medieval Europe.
A lot in medieval Europe.
I mean you look at the figures per hundred thousand because some of them have
over a hundred a hundred thousand 150 to a hundred thousand and medieval Europe.
A lot of these cities were like 20 per hundred thousand.
So they're way worse that way.
Worse than the wild west than like now there are some place in the United
States,
the de la I and I did and I've done some research recently in Baltimore Marin
hand and I was kind of,
it's interesting to compare that to Latin America and that's a high level.
That's 4,400 thousands that's not as the same level,
but a significant still more than medieval Europe.
Yeah.
Wow.
Baltimore's worst in medieval Europe.
Yeah.
I'm going to ask the cause you have to have to some professors then they want a,
like you get like,
you know,
they might be,
they might say,
well Jerusalem in this time or in a line,
I know you've got triumph.
When I saw it,
note that it really dig down exactly that there was outbreaks of violence and
killing in certain places,
but the overall average of all average year,
that's a significant leap.
100% leap.
Yeah,
yeah,
absolutely.
Yeah.
Baltimore,
what about South side of Chicago?
It's not that,
I mean like the level I think in Chicago comes out around 20 or something.
So it's not now the,
that of the host city.
Now these again,
and one of the things about the violence in the United States compared to Latin
America,
I mean Baltimore is,
is,
is significant parts of fairly what the city of Baltimore is a fairly small
place where they're talking about,
so in Mexico you have entire states that are like really violent or entire
countries in Latin America,
whereas in the U s it tends to be neighborhoods which are violent.
Um,
so if you really focus
on the south side of Chicago,
I,
it's probably similar levels to Baltimore thing.
[inaudible] um,
but if you look at the whole city,
you've got neighbors that are pretty safe in Chicago's will you?
I grew up with an alcoholic father and it was a pretty violent home and,
and he was a really bad alcoholic.
And I know having grown up in that,
you wind up with what I call a damage,
personal truth and you feel second class and the problem that kids make and uh,
cause I know I did it and I see others do it is you compare your personal truth,
what you know about yourself and how you really live and what's really going on.
You compare your personal truth to everybody else's social mask because you go
to school and you know,
well I know that last night the windows got kicked out of my house.
I know that the utilities got turned off and I know there was a big fight in my
kitchen last night and the kid sitting next to me,
he's got on a shirt that's all ironed and his face is all bright and clean and
you know,
he looks like he's just got it all together.
And you compare yourself to that person,
that kid and you feel like you're second class.
And the problem with that is we generate the results in life we think we
deserve.
So if you think your damaged,
do you think your second class you will generate
results that you think a second class person deserves?
So if you don't fix your personal truth,
then you'll spend the rest of your life saying,
well you know those really good results,
those belong for somebody else.
That's not for me.
That's for somebody else.
And you'll settle for second best and you won't get what you might otherwise
generate for yourself if you don't fix your personal truth.
And so I think a lot of people are struggling looking for a way to kind of get
out of feeling not good about themselves and damaged self esteem,
damage,
self worth.
And they really don't know where to go.
So,
uh,
and that's why I do show,
I don't look,
I'm not under the misapprehension that we're doing eight minute cures up there.
I mean come on you,
we're not doing it.
But I think if you can point people in the right direction,
if you can raise their awareness,
you can get them thinking about it.
You can create a narrative where they at least say,
you know,
how do I feel about myself?
I mean,
is there stuff I need to resolve?
what am I saying to myself?
If you can get them thinking about that,
then you know,
maybe you've done something.
Yeah.
You know,
Tony Robbins once said once said,
it's incremental changes over the long haul and the way you have to look at it
as if these two boats are going in a parallel direction and one of them just
shifts five degrees over the course of time.
This boat is going to be in a far different place than the other boat.
That's in the same way it was always going.
Yeah.
And the important thing to realize as well is the next year is going to go by
whether you're doing something about your life or not.
I mean we're,
we're sitting here right now at the end of February and the next 10 months are
going to go by whether somebody is working to make change or whether they're
not.
And they may think,
you know,
Oh my God,
I'm so far away and I'll never get it under control or I'm so behind in my bills
or I'm so,
uh,
you know,
just depressed or,
uh,
my,
everything is so out of control.
Well,
you know what,
you make those incremental changes and then you know,
pretty soon in December you go,
Hey,
I'm way better off than I was at the end of February.
So Shit,
you made little changes and they all added up.
And if you don't,
by the end of the year,
you're just in deeper.
So every little bit matters.
And there's a,
it's a seems to be like a universal struggle for figuring out what people are
and how we should behave and who gets to decide that.
And there's certain universal truths are ignored and there's certain ones that
our emphasis over emphasized and there's certain ones that are,
you know,
that are in the goldilocks spot and we were working it out.
I think that's part of what's going on with human beings,
but will,
we have to be really,
really careful of is that by silencing some people and never giving them any
path to retribution,
we create eternal enemies.
And this is,
this is what easily could be happening right now when someone doesn't have
ability to express themselves
because an evil force wants conflict.
And what you say is totally know if it's an evil force,
but it's an archetypal force there.
They're listening to all those around them.
And there's a hive hive mind sort of thinking to a lot of this.
There's not a lot of debate about,
so I like,
let's just say this Joe and,
and to,
um,
10th planet.
Everybody else.
You didn't give into the pressuring of the threat.
It was more than nagging like a siren,
like a bitching woman,
not against women,
but I mean I get it by us and so that's why you didn't have me on,
but then you realize I was just a symbol of you just trying to live the life and
put out good ideas and talk to people.
But folks,
you're going to make you choose a side and that's what's happening in this
quickening is I don't want to choose a side.
Ryan Seacrest has got it nailed.
Nobody's coming to Ryan Seacrest for like political advice.
He's got it nailed.
He hosts a bunch of shows.
A real nice guys.
Got a great smile.
He figured it out.
But
you understand that you are looking at that sweet spot,
man.
I looking at you going dummy,
we are talking about anything and everything.
Oh my God.
Entropy is stagnant water.
Oh it's still nothing's going on.
It's all clear.
It's dead and rotting.
What's alive?
Ocean big crashing.
Yes it's Jersey.
I,
I've seen beyond that.
Everybody has,
but I've,
I've seen way beyond cause you want to be in the conflict,
you want to be in the fight,
you want to take all your,
you're not successful Joe.
Cause you played along with the system.
You're successful because you did it organically and real doesn't mean it's
perfect.
Doesn't mean it's bad.
It was real.
That's why your success and then they come in and you think,
oh I'm not saying you're bad.
I'm the same way.
Oh all these people are telling me how great I am.
I play ball with them because I've got,
you know this thing.
But they want you because they're soulless.
And so all I'm saying is you've made the right decision and I don't,
I'm just saying having beyond because I'm not perfect is deciding no,
America,
sill America,
the world,
still the world.
We're allowed to talk about real things and here real things because they want
to shut other voices down so they can lie about those voices.
And,
and any idea that fears,
exposure or fears,
debate is a failed idea.
When you guys wrote songs,
how did you,
how did you put the lyrics to the music?
What was the process like?
How did you guys sort that out?
So you,
would you come to them with an idea?
Would they come to you with a riff?
Like how,
how would,
how would it work?
It'll work,
uh,
a number of ways.
But a mistake that a lot of young writers in my department,
the lyrics make is that they think of it as secondary.
Mm.
They wait for the music or the track first and then you'll walk into a studio
and hope that the hand of God will descend and grace you with a amazing
epiphany's.
I can't even spell amazing.
All right.
Um,
and called upon to do it right away.
You know,
you'll work out a beat and go,
Dave,
you got some lyrics.
If I go walk into that room and try to create it right there,
nine times out of 10,
it's going to be moving in June,
right?
Moon and June.
Really when?
Sometime soon.
What time of day?
I'm thinking noon and literally I'm gonna put my hands in the air.
Why?
Well,
cause I just don't care.
You wind up there unless you're banking.
Think like debate.
If you're going to debate somebody,
you're banking your ideas,
right?
Alright.
And whatever the subject is,
you can go,
you don't even have to have a subject itch.
Okay.
I like what he just said.
I might even write that phrase.
I like what you just said.
Could be a Drake lyric.
Any expressions,
ideas,
slogans,
uh,
anything that comes,
other tunes in terms of their lyric.
And is everybody contributing?
No,
that's just me.
Just to have volumes of that and those kinds of ideas,
ideas for songs,
storylines,
et Cetera.
Um,
you would never go into a fight without doing that.
Collecting moves from every other film of every other fighter that you possibly
can,
so that when somebody goes like this,
you go,
oh,
I know what to do.
So on and so forth.
And then I'm going to visit like this.
And somebody says it's a song about they play a song.
I go,
wow,
it sounds kinda like cowboy music.
Let's write about cowboys going through the banking.
Giddyup
that's cool.
Title.
I heard a cowboy,
I say it on the TV set and I wrote it down literally.
Okay.
And you start bay,
you get,
I see the lights come and you start banking.